hello and welcome back to the chess
website this is Justin and today we're
going to be doing a little bit of a
different kind of video instead of going
over some openings or going over some
chess general information we're actually
going to be looking at some pretty
recent games and going to be talking
about some recent developments in the
world of Chess so let me know in the
comments what you guys think about this
kind of video and if you guys have any
suggestions for videos we could do in
the future we just want to help provide
a great learning environment for you so
thanks for watching let's get right into
it so the games and what I'm going to
talk about today is the modern chess
opening so recently in the US Women's
Championship Carissa Yip who is a very
strong player rated
2370 and an international Master she
played the modern defense against
multiple of her opponents who are also
very very strong Masters so the modern
opening is considered to be kind of a
bad opening it starts after E4 and then
G6 so instead of playing for the center
right away black is just kind of playing
on the side of the board not
really trying to do anything with the
center it's a really interesting
approach and this is called
the modern because this is kind of a
modern way of playing chess it was a
modern way of playing chess because
again instead of fighting for the center
right away it's inviting white to take
over the center and basically saying all
right you can have the center but I'm
going to fight back and I'm going to be
able to retake the center so this game
does a great job of showing how the
modern works and how black can actually
chip away the center and slowly take it
back under its own control so after
white gains all of the space in the
center it looks like white is just
dominating this opening black plays a
strange looking move A6 this looks
really weird like what is A6 doing how
does that help Black's position but
after Knight F3 Carissa plays B5 and we
see a little bit of the idea here
Carissa wants to play Bishop to
B7 attacking and pressuring this E4 pawn
and then play B 4 which would undermine
the defender of this E4 Pawn so a very
strange looking idea but the idea again
is to undermine the center with the mod
so white plays Bishop to D3 solidifying
that center Bishop to B7 and Black's
pieces look pretty good these Bishops
are doing a great job of controlling and
fighting for the center even though
black has zero Pawns in the center and
as very cramped as far as their space so
white wants to take advantage of Black's
kind of lack of following the opening
principles and white plays E5 this is
generally a good idea if your opponent
is not following the opening principles
you want to open things up you want to
punish them for it so after E5 Carissa
says okay well you're just overextending
right you've pushed all these Pawns in
the center but you're actually just
weakening your position because pawns
can't go backwards so Carissa strikes
with
C5 and now there's all of this tension
in the center so many sides so many
captures are possible here um but the
bottom line is after all of these
captures so for instance uh White takes
here and then black actually takes on E5
and the idea here is that this Knight
cannot take because that would hang this
G2 Pawn all the way back back here and
then white would have a hard time
castling so um after d takes E5 white
just castles and that um allows the
center to already just be evaporated we
had three Pawns in the center just a few
moves ago and all of a sudden it's gone
so this is the power and this is the
idea of the modern is to fight back
against that strong Center and try to
undermine it slowly and chip away at it
so um that really what I want to
emphasize and and this idea of the
modern way of playing chess which is to
allow your opponent to get the center
and then fight back and say you've
overextended you can't move those pawns
backwards um so the rest of this
game um is really interesting to look at
but essentially black just plays pretty
normal moves this move Queen C8 is a
little odd um but the idea is just we're
going to be able to take back with the
queen if you take on C6 and that's just
what happens um and then uh a few moves
go by just normal developing moves and
if we see a few moves go on from here we
see that all of the sudden like has
completely flipped the script instead of
white dominating the center now black is
there's just complete domination of the
center by black the bishop and the queen
work beautifully along this long
diagonal completely unchallenged and
these pawns do a great great job of
controlling important Central
squares so um we can kind of see that
the strength of the modern here and and
why the center is so strong because now
now that black has the center and white
had
overextended white really can't
challenge black center they don't have
any pawn breaks because their pawns had
already moved so they can't play a move
like D4 and try to you know fight back
at the center because they don't have a
D- Pawn they already pushed it like it's
it's gone so it's a really interesting
way of playing chess and this is um
becoming more and more popular for a few
reasons and we'll get into that a little
bit later but Carissa went on to win
this game very very smoothly um and it's
just very very impressive how she did
this just completely let her opponent
from the start just dominate the center
and she fought back and was able to chip
it away and very very quickly just
completely relieve all of VO Central
control so uh I'll look at a few more
moves it's not really that important but
just the two Bishops here and black is
up in
exchange and you know a ton of material
two pawns as well has even with all that
material black has really nice control
of the center so white really has
nothing to play for at this point um and
the game ends uh pretty shortly after
this it's already like minus5 so it's
crazy to start from a position like this
where white just has everything they
could want to a few moves later black
having complete domination over the
position and white having no counterplay
at all it's really fascinating how this
Modern Way of playing chess can work and
Karissa used this multiple times in this
tournament with very very good success
and this game against Anna Zony a very
strong player
2360 she used this strategy again it
started with D4 so a little bit
different but it ended up being very
similar because after Knight to F6 she
just went G6 again she's not putting any
Pawns in the center she's allowing her
opponents to take the center and then
fighting back and chipping away at that
Center so after G6 Knight to D2 again
playing a move like D5 here makes a ton
of sense it just stops E4 Stakes its
claim in the center but Carissa wants no
part of that she's just saying I'm GNA
give you the center and and white does
it and it's very very interesting the
way she's playing this and just getting
a very unbalanced position where she's
going to have chances to play for the
win so after this she plays Knight to C6
and then E5 this is her chipping away at
the center she finally breaks through in
the center and if white were to play a
move like D5 here black would just play
Knight to E7 they would move this Knight
to like H5 and play F5 and they would
still have a lot of ways to chip away at
this overextended Center that white has
so C6 is also another break it's just
very fascinating how sometimes taking
the center and and putting all of your
Pawns in the center can actually be a
bad thing um and if you play principal
chess it's shouldn't be but at this top
level where these these very strong
players really understand the game of
chess it's very fascinating to see how
they just let their opponents take the
center
so in this position the center is pretty
even but this Modern Way of playing
chess with this G6 the bishop G7 like
she was happy to just let her opponent
take over the center and then all the
sudden now um now the center is pretty
much under her control it's it's pretty
even but um as black this is this is
perfectly fine so Queen E2 H6 I'm not
going to go too in depth with the game
itself um but I did just want to show
and emphasize how the opening allowed
her to get an unbalanced position now
there's a lot of light squares around
White's King that are weak and that
allows her to create a very strong
attack so she goes H5 really just going
after White's
king queen F2 and then she brings all of
her pieces into the game Bishop H6 and
here uh funnily enough um Bishop H6 was
actually a blunder um very very
difficult to see why Queen C5 is uh the
the way to punish this because both C7
and E5 are weak especially um E5 e is an
important pawn and apparently this is
like plus three very difficult for a
human to understand especially with all
of Black's pieces pointing towards the
king and nothing defending it from White
side but just Bishop F1 is coming and
that's going to kick the queen out and
that should be enough but regardless
Bishop F1 comes the queen Retreats and
then H4 black is just breaking through
black is doing everything it can to to
break away at White's position and and
then G takes H4 and now white wants or
sorry black wants to get their Rooks
into the game so they do that by playing
King to G7 and they're going to swing
their Rook all the way around to
h8 and try to mop up this H4 Pawn so
Knight G2 a very passive move white
should have been a little bit more
aggressive and that kind of allowed
Kissa to play a move like Knight H5 and
improve her pieces this Knight can head
to F4 in a lot of positions where it's
going to be very well
placed Bishop to B5 The Rook goes to h8
which was her plan all along and then
Bishop C4 the queen goes to F6 all of
black pieces again are pointing towards
White's King and after Queen C5 Bishop
H3 it's just collapsing um we'll see a
few more moves Queen E7 Queen takes F3
and that Queen is is really uh causing a
lot of problems for
white wait takes on E5 with check then
plays Bishop to
F1 but here just the move Knight to F4
is good enough um to win because after
this move uh taking on F4 would not be a
great idea since Bishop takes F4 it's
going to come followed by Bishop to
E3 and you know attacking this queen is
also a pretty big deal um so that's a
pretty big threat and you're also just
threatening to take on
G2 so Rook to D2 and you just take on G2
Rook takes G2 Knight H3 check and now
King to H1 is forced and here Carissa
Play Bishop to E3 just slowly
suffocating that white king and then
after Queen takes C7 Knight F2
check King to G1 and see if you can find
the finish
here Karissa played Knight to D1 check
and he here an a Zony resign because
this is a discovery check and more
importantly it cuts off the connection
between this rook and the bishop so once
the king moves Queen takes F1 is going
to lead to mate because there's no
protection of that Bishop so really
interesting opening and to see how Kissa
uses opening to just get some random
positions positions where black is going
to have a fighting chance for opponent
is not going to be familiar she's going
to be
uncomfortable and it led to a huge
tournament for her and a great great
success so the modern was really revived
by Carissa Yip in this tournament a very
interesting approach to what seemed to
be a dead opening and it's got a lot of
bonuses it surprises your opponents it
puts them in your territory and there's
really not a lot of memorization if you
just kind of understand the ideas of
trying to break down the center there's
a lot of ways you can go about it but
you really don't need to memorize
anything and the last part which is a
lot of the appeal of the modern chess
opening is it's Dynamic it's not just
boring it's not the Berlin defense it's
not a force draw in 20 moves especially
at the highest level it's a dynamic
position it's going to get you a
position where all three results are
possible and there's a lot of chest left
to be played so the modern chess opening
is a really fascinating Revelation was
recently introduced to the top Chess
World by chissa Yip and let me know what
you think about it in the comments
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time